we had shirtless tyler c
totally checked himself out goodbye to
katie i can't give you this rose tonight
and
heather's here for matty
this is your the bachelor season 25
episode six recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and roses
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
and guess what some news so
exciting i'm not alone
[Applause]
jc is here he's back in the studio with
me
on our second camera and i am
overwhelmed i am overjoyed
i am overly enthusiastic no i'm not this
is a big deal
he's got a suit on too i'll show you
guys a little behind the scenes video
we're still staying six feet apart
looking great
full suit doesn't mess around with his
workplace attire
both assuming some meta oh
everybody so much to be happy about i
absolutely
loved this episode of the bachelor we
had good looking people
we had humor we had a minivan
what did you think of this episode let
me know in the comments below
let's get to it does my actions speak
louder than my words see i lead by
example just seniors and we started that
off by picking up where we left off with
mj and yesenia or as mj called her
a little i can't stand her
such a little [ __ ] but as a reminder
she preaches harmony and peace
and at the end of the day i know you
need a wife that preaches for harmony
and peace
yeah you know there was a lot of talk
about [ __ ] you know what a weak [ __ ]
does is
i had a weak [ __ ] moment but i'm back
i'm going to keep being a bad [ __ ] this
is not going to shake me
mj is finding a need to throw around
curse words
not justia no no no
she just calls mj by her full name this
is who i
am you know what meredith oh that's cute
there's only one other meredith i know
and it is very
apropo
[Music]
so yeah mj and jesenya are arguing and i
do
know what they're arguing about but this
is just some of the worst arguing i've
ever seen
mj keeps talking over her literally
yourself
this is so petty then saying she won't
let her talk no jessenia
you've done enough talking i need to
talk mj it's definitely not the bad
[ __ ] energy
you claim to be bringing i'm gonna keep
being a bad [ __ ] this is not gonna
shake me
at all this is done where did you guys
land in this
conflict i very much sided with jesenya
in this
argument no i did see some of you
pointing out that jacenya had made a
couple catty comments about other women
in previous episodes
it's a little too cocky these girls just
kind of swoop in
so you know the question is becoming are
any of these women
not messy have any of them risen above
this situation
and shameless plug i asked matt james
that question
yes i interviewed him and matt told me
that the only person he could guarantee
wasn't involved was michelle you know
michelle wasn't involved in anything
every time
i spoke with michelle it was super
intentional and it was about our
relationship it's no cheers to michelle
[Applause]
but matt sided with jesenya ii and he
sent meredith home mj
i can't give you this i don't know how
she did this
and she sabotaged me mj didn't own an
atone you guys
oh yes i am writing it all down
but it's the rose ceremony cannot
receive rose take a moment
say goodbyes and we are saying bye to
brittany and ryan
and and and
to maggie hey
my person is definitely always there
you know what maggie did not get in the
mess i'm gonna add her name to that list
maggie for paradise or is she just too
pure for all of this
let me know in the comments below so two
of the new women did go home britney and
ryan and ryan is quite upset
she says she didn't get enough time to
talk to and connect with matt it's just
really hard not to think about having
more time with him and having a
conversation tonight
that could have changed things i just
want to take a quick moment to discuss
rejection i don't think it's about not
having the time with matt
if he wanted to talk to you he would
it's not rejection
it just wasn't right it's not rejection
it just wasn't right you don't have to
see someone not
choosing you as a negative reflection of
you
like i'm not gonna mix up chardonnay and
rose and drink them together
but i love them both it's love
[Music]
but we are moving forward and we're
focusing on the love
right right oh no wait serena c's gonna
confront katie basically
i am just super frustrated of time
continuously being taken away
by your antics no yes
just when we think we're in the clear
just when we believe
we've gotten a reprieve just when we
feel there's
light at the end of the tunnel we swim
in the deep dark seas we
feel we hope we think we've got a
glimmer of a chance at something better
nope i don't know why i went hepburn
there but you know what we go with it
because
the show's about drama and so am i i
feel alive and i love it
i need a little lost something's
happening to me
okay was that a good headburn i don't
know let me know in the comments below
now you have it judge it so i could work
on it i could work shop it
not a rejection maybe it wasn't right
you're letting all these little fires
everywhere you are the freaking arsonist
serena c is coming after katie starting
to claim that katie's not really here
for matt
the reason why i'm coming to you is
because i don't think that you were
truly here for matt
and this was hard to process because i
didn't want to listen to any more
bickering
who i am here i am here i am
here but i took it in and i remembered
sometimes life throws stuff at you and
you gotta deal with it
you gotta take what comes your way
you've got to face what these
winds will blow at you the time to make
up your mind about people
is never
and so i gotta talk about it serena
crashes a sleepover
you guys i just had the most
heated conversation and some of the
ladies are having a floor sit
which i love i find something about it
to be a bit more comforting than sitting
on a couch
or on a bed it's like when you're
sitting on the floor you are grounded
you know you are finding peace you are
finding strength you are getting it from
gravity you're really really really not
going anywhere and you can absolutely
relax and sprawl out and just
be what you need to be there's no
judgment on the floor you know you're
already sitting on it so hey
say anything you want about me i'm
already at my lowest point and that's
what's nice about it it's just that you
can just
[Music]
so yeah she's at the girls night and
talking to the other women about
katie all of her little antics keep
taking up our time with matt where we
should be progressing with him
but our mature queen our adult
in the room our absolute elder when it
comes to maturity and communication
now i'm starting to sound like margaret
thatcher will you support me
the crown katie goes there
to clear the air yes katie is going to
address
the situation i'm just telling them what
you told me so
that your main focus is not to be with
matt that's what i told you you thought
that was the gist of it okay well i
obviously said nothing like that so
don't speak on my behalf ever and long
story short i sided with katie here did
you let me know in the comments below
i just felt like serena you don't need
to concern yourself with what katie's
doing
you seem to be feeling insecure about
your relationship with matt and you're
taking that out on katie
focus on you but speaking of
groundedness
heather from golden season is here hello
yes heather martin has showed up
why is she in a minivan
i can't figure it out you guys and it's
cracking me up if she
flew there and got a rental car why
choose a minivan
were they fresh out i i kind of love it
it's so weird what do you think let me
know in the comments below
how's it going my name is heather
heather
martin was on colton underwood's season
of the bachelor
and this moment had been much teased to
hi chris heather what are you doing here
oh gosh
and it actually felt very real to me
what did you guys think of heather's
arrival
heather showed up and said hannah brown
is her bestie
she just spent some time with matt in
quarantine and like the first thing she
said to me when she landed is like
this guy is like the perfect match for
you i couldn't
let him get engaged and not meet him
uh chris harrison is here socially
distanced
he tells her that he can't let her in
because she's gonna have to
quarantine so we're in quarantine
and we're pretty far into this and then
he just started using some wording and
phrasing that
i don't know really cracked me up he was
like i gotta take this up the hill
i will take this up the hill okay i need
to talk to a lot of people
and he literally did because there was a
hill behind him
i got to take this up this hill can they
let her on they got to figure it out
up the hill and then my personal
favorite
an absolute gem i'm not gonna be
forgetting this one
chris and his vest say just when you
think you've seen it all
just when you think you've seen it all
just when you think you've seen it all
just when you think you've seen it all
gotta go up the hill hill
costumes just when you think you've seen
it all
so they're gonna figure that out up on
the mountain um but down in the valley
piper
is deciding which set of gold hoops
specifically she's gonna wear on this
one-on-one
yes piper has the one-on-one and matt
picks her up and piper's like
where are we yeah where are we and i'm
like
good question it's really dark
what are we doing out in the woods out
in the night
ooh something different oh it's a
carnival
what what why look i'm not saying there
was anything wrong with this date it was
fine
it's just that i personally myself
fundamentally
i've been wanting a survival date yeah
like you know the survival shows like
bear grylls
oh take a look never underestimate the
power of a woman's vanity case
i want to see people build a shelter
build a fire
have to survive together you know you
want to talk about testing a
relationship
can you build a fire for me i don't need
you to shoot a water gun and win one of
those animals
oh am i wrong you guys let me know in
the comments below
but i don't want those like if some guy
wins me one of those i'm like what do i
do with this
i don't want this in my home i want a
fire because i like an outdoor fire pit
moment
yeah and you know they say they're
having fun
but i wasn't laughing so like one of
those spinny things i think they got in
one it like holds you to the side or
something
let's just speed through this and matt
and piper are at dinner and they are
talking about her family
the culture in my family overall is we
we don't really say love she's opening
up
and she says she is falling in love with
matt matt
i am falling in love with you and piper
gets a rose
piper you accept this rose
what did you guys think of this date i
will say
i need to see more emotion from matt
it's been several episodes i need to see
his emotion but we're gonna get more
into that later for now
let's talk about heather martin
vlogging i am here
i'm quarantining she's vlogging in her
hotel room
i am hoping and i'm praying that
i can get through this she's balancing a
pizza on her head
look at that if that's not impressive
oh i have to say you guys i
appreciate heather trying to bring us
some comedy i really do and while
heather is alone
quarantining the women go on a group
date
yes we are bowling so bowling bowling
sports sports sports and chris harrison
arrives to give the winning team a
trophy
ladies get up here get your trophy and
they get to go to the after party the
losing team does not
blue bombshells it's time to say your
goodbyes you'll be going home tonight
and i don't want to shock anybody but
the losing team
is upset about their lack of time i'm
not getting any time it's not even
a little bit of time i'm just not
getting any time no time with matt
tonight it's just the most
frustrating thing and i wanted to ask
you babes are we usually this upset
about time with the lead at this point
in the show
i don't know if that's in part because
they're affected by not being able to
travel
like they're getting a little stir crazy
and or if it's because there are
so many women on mats season maybe they
really aren't getting as much time as
the contestants usually do
hello ladies oh but now chris harrison
is the gift that keeps on giving
literally
first he gave a trophy now he's giving
the losers a special date card
i don't often come and deliver a
personal date card to go
to the after party abigail serena see
kate bree and rachel i feel
terrible about today i need time with
you
please everything's
fine time
that was katherine hepburn meets
voldemort we're going down a weird path
so the losing team shows up to the after
party
sorry to crash the party no you're not
and matt continues to be
loki the women all get there and he's
like hey
[Music]
hey
surprise and i am whipping through
things today
michelle gets the rose michelle
you accept this rose yes oh and poor one
out for heather she's still alone in
that room
pretending to be rapunzel i am rapunzel
i'm just going to let down my hair i can
just climb
up an oscar-worthy performance
heather isn't with matt she's not there
but guess who is tyler
cameron
man what's up my man oh everybody
it was so nice to see tyler c back on
our screens
what did you think let me know in the
comment below
yes tyler cameron is here to hang out
with his friend matt and
you know that's what they do they're two
dudes
playing pool
what why why would they do this it
seemed incredibly off-brand
didn't it uh they were playing pool and
given everything that we know about
their friendship their relationship
their roommateship
they really should have been shirtless
doing a workout together
we've freaking watched matt on his
peloton we can't now get him and tyler i
don't know doing a sweaty little spin
class
i'm just saying we've been through a lot
of kind of anger and hating we could all
use a little joy
and this was even kind of a quick
conversation a very short little pool
game
it felt brief and they weren't even in
briefs
but wait do not fear
this show is the gift that keeps on
giving
hi katie got a one-on-one
and it includes a prank on tyler cameron
today katie's in charge i'm in the
co-pilot seat
and we're gonna ruin his day and pranks
are fun and then
and then
it's the gift that keeps on giving
everybody
and it's giving tyler cameron a massage
you can hang your robe here when you're
ready i'll step out for a second
they know what we want you know they do
we question them and we critique them
and we're allowed to do that but they
also know what we want
so tyler thinks he is getting a massage
and apparently the masseuse is in on
this prank and matt and katie are going
to be in her ear
telling her what to do and you know what
did you think of matt and katie's
directives
to the masseuse alice can you start to
work your way to his nipples yeah there
you go
it was mostly physical humor even some
nipple twisting
twist has nipples occasionally too
[Music]
i thought we could have weirded him out
a little more you know like some strange
questions from the masseuse but
it's fine can you start to work your way
to his nipples yeah it's the dinner
portion and
katie with the run and jump is this the
first of the season
how are you doing good how are you great
are we
having fun again a great evening
uh no hijinks matt and katie's dinner
really helped me
pinpoint what my issue is with matt's
emotional
sharing i did a lot of reflecting and
realized i was not being
who i was truly meant to be we don't
know anything
about matt's romantic relationship
history matt has talked about his family
and some issues he has there
but remember we didn't get to see matt
as a contestant on the show
so we have no awareness of
past heartbreaks he's had and he hasn't
talked about him at all
and matt is a very good listener he asks
great questions
what's that looked like for you in the
past like relationship wise
but ah
no rose for katie
i can't give you this rose tonight
old timey motion picture death
[Music]
i still got my eyes on you like matt
i can't give you this rose tonight yes
matt
tells katie that the connection just
isn't there
i just haven't had those feelings that i
need to have
finding a wife in this process were you
shocked
were you surprised i was not but let me
know in the comments below
i have felt for a minute that matt and
katie had a bit more of a friendship
than a romantic relationship and i
appreciated that matt just
told her was up front with her you've
been honest with me
and otto the same honesty to you oh but
a producer comes to take katie's
suitcase and the ladies were
surprised don't drink for every person
who puts a
hand over their mouth
you knew what i was doing oh but it's
over
i just didn't see that coming at all and
matt cinematically
walks away into a foggy night and katie
is driven away in a car
i don't regret being myself
it just sucks that it wasn't enough
and i've got to ask i have to pose the
question we must have the discussion
katie for bachelorette babes there's
honestly not a ton of selection from
this season
and i also think there are many reasons
to support katie or if you have any
other suggestions of course
let me know in the comments below oh but
from going
to coming heather martin is finally able
to stop vlogging yes we can tell that
heather is
going to get out of there because there
is a camera in there with her she's not
just on her iphone she's being
professionally filmed oh and the other
cameras are busy too it is the cocktail
party and they are shooting the women
from up above
and they are shooting them coming in and
everything is happening oh gosh and i
wrote down even though the cameras were
with heather they made her drive herself
to the party
oh my gosh look at that in that minivan
highs and lows you know the van is
pulling up she's getting out of the van
and she's stuck in the spinny door
it's a new girl it's not anybody i've
never seen this girl
oh oh oh it's the gift that keeps on
giving this was the comedy i needed
she's like oh god oh
i don't i can't really i can't really
move my arms in this and i'm just
can anyone oh you can't can you help me
no you can't because we have to six feet
apart but i'm
stuck i'm quarantining in the door i
would like to listen i've been alone for
six days and uh
maybe 14 days i don't really know comedy
oh matt is laughing
and i am laughing but the ladies are not
what the and then we get the promo
next week on the bachelor and shockingly
it looks like the women are going to be
mean to heather
you guys don't know me at all do you
know matt at all like [ __ ] what are you
doing oh
but it also looks emotional everything
that he said he's felt for me has been a
lie
my heart's falling in another direction
which is good because i want the
emotions
i cannot wait for next week and i truly
loved this episode again
what did you guys think let me know in
the comments below i do remember that
shameless plug
[Music]
chris harrison told me in a pre-season
interview that we really kind of break
down mass emotions and i'm ready to see
that happen
we will be back next week of course if
you want to connect with me more
you can find me on tick tock twitter
instagram
laurenzema and you can get a personal
message from me
on the app cameo and i want to thank i
want to raise a glass too
we all want to run and jump in his arms
but we can't
jc hello so glad to have him back
so happy to be back with you guys thank
you so much for watching
roses and rose now i gotta
head up the hill just when you think
you've seen it all
[Music]
you